has normalizing sex work like only fans
been a benefit for women
i mean there clearly are some women only
fans who make a lot of money from it so
there are some
winners i mean
they
they are very unusual most women on only
fans probably make a loss in terms of
the amount of time they have to spend
because the pareto distribution on only
fans is wild and most of the women who
do really well on it are already
celebrities and already quite wealthy
so this idea that you can just be
like
as long as you're sufficiently pretty
you log on and you're making a fortune
is not true and i'm sure has been
deliberately whipped up that idea by
only fans because they're the only
people actually really profiting at the
end of the day um i mean i think the
early fans is not like street
prostitution or growth or property like
it's clearly not the same
i
i
like it's pretty gross and and you will
have men asking you to do things that
really turn your stomach
but it's clearly not like physically
dangerous i think that the main
risk of only fans is your
ability to have a long-term relationship
afterwards because you end up putting
your images out in the world and you
can't get them back that's the nature of
the internet and often only fans
creators get their images stolen
and so they'll be shared and they don't
even get any money from it
and
the risk is
in the future that even though
men don't always admit it
the sexual double standard is still
actually really alive and well if you so
sexually double standard being when
men are kind of permitted to be a bit
promiscuous and that's okay socially but
women tend to be punished for
promiscuity i think that only fans goes
beyond promiscuity you know
the double standard didn't occur it's
not men wanking on camera and then
trying to find a wife and them saying uh
my friends shared something in a
whatsapp chat earlier on and that kind
of looks a little bit like you
what about um
normalizing uh
like love sex workers like sex workers
are you should be completely fine with
your partner doing only fans or uh
perhaps even escorting
i mean crazy what kind of
yeah i mean either
i think if i think if a man is really
comfortable with that that's like a red
flag to me
honestly like again it's an example of
men suppressing their instincts because
the the the instinct towards jealousy is
so strong
and again has such an obvious
evolutionary
origin to it
um
because if you're putting loads of
resources into raising children that
you've had with this woman you want to
know they're yours like that's make
guarding is what the
um
biologists call it and it's it's so
common that i think it's considered to
be a human universal
and yeah like there are there are loads
of
sort of unwelcome phenomena that come
from that you know jealousy is often
um the motive behind domestic violence
for instance
it's like you know
you mention the naturalistic fallacy
like the fact that it's natural doesn't
mean it's necessarily good but it does
also mean that trying to completely
override it is probably not going to
work
like you have to find a way of
accommodating your instincts you can't
just try and suppress them and try and
like
like rewrite the human blueprint well
that's where that's where i think the um
it's not men that are encouraging women
to do only funds
i don't see men on the internet
saying that you should go and you girl
should ditch your job and go and do it
the only people online saying sex work
is real work
seems to be women yes
men are the ones that are paying for
their images once they're in the game
but i think
that's because once women cross that
threshold and become a sex worker or
whatever they're almost
kind of not subhuman but they're in a
different category right and it's like
oh well they're doing it i didn't get
them into it so i'm just going to
continue to fund them but if you were to
say
to most men i think
would you advise that pretty girl to get
into only fan so that you can see her
nudes
most of them would say
probably not probably not but almost
every healthy man would say no right
they'd say no i'd try and go out with
her or maybe she should just go and
enjoy her life or do whatever but once
they're in the game that's what's going
to happen but you have this this very
bizarre sort of cartel
i don't know it's like
uh
self not self oppression but like
self-capitalization from women of women
encouraging other women to go and do the
game despite the fact that the chances
of you making money on only fans is
minuscule when it comes to actually
making the tens of thousands of dollars
a day that the the biggest creators make
and
yeah i mean
even even if you were able to have an
unbelievably secure only fans
that was never able to leak your photos
online you have two choices for the
remainder of your life when you get into
talking to a new partner you can either
tell them the truth
and
regardless of how comfortable that guy
is with his sexuality finding out that
his misses forget body count even if
you've only slept with
one other person but that was something
that you did
you can't
like left brain your way out of thinking
that that is
oh god well if she did that in the past
does this mean that she's maybe going to
she's a risk for promiscuity in the
future like the cook radar is so hyper
attuned for men which is why we get more
jealous or the other one is to lie to
him
cut radar is interesting
phrase
good coinage game because i have you
because i have used the i've i've i have
to write it in the book but i've
um like talked about on twitter nonce
radar
[Laughter]
i think that women have really strongly
i mean i think men do as well but i
think women in particular have a really
strong like it's i think it's certainly
a sexual disgust thing is that feeling
of like this guy is creepy
and i think that it i think it's like
female intuition right and i think it's
coming it's probably partly coming from
wanting to protect yourself is also
partly wanting to protect your children
you've got that like this guy's bad news
yeah if i'm going to sleep with him
what's he going to do to the kids
perhaps
i got to tell you about this uh
meme that i saw so carl benjamin sargon
of akkad a guy who uh has incredibly
conservative views about this stuff but
aligns completely with what we're saying
here he posted a meme the other day and
it had a girl from only fans in like a
bikini or laundry or whatever sort of
dancing away on one side and had michael
scott from the office on the other side
of looking strangely and the text said
we call it female empowerment and they
will dance naked for the price of a
cheeseburger what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace